this program is brought to you by the
emory university center for ethics hi
I'm Kate Powell and today I'll be
talking with John banja a medical
ethicist with the Emory center for
ethics and a professor in the Department
of Rehabilitation medicine he has
authored many publications including the
book medical errors and medical
narcissism I like to say that that you
know responsibility for error oftentimes
is collective it should be it probably
mostly should be shared by individuals
but but we must work very very hard to
stifle that first response which is to
to blame and to punish them primarily
because number one everybody makes
mistakes and everyone makes errors and
number two the actual harm that results
from eric is usually a function of the
system rather than a single person doing
something inexplicably stupid than
causes harm to somebody well I think
that you cannot know enough about
medical errors and about how they happen
and about how to talk and communicate
about them in fact Kate I I would say it
is probably a life's work learning how
they happen learning how systems work
learning how people because they start
getting careless for example they start
deviating from policies and protocols
and standards of care not because
they're evil or malicious but because
it's just easier for them they can get
through their work faster by doing it
their way and
doing it their way might act as a matter
of fact invite more risk to patients and
and and and so on so I want to raise the
banner for education and learning as
much as we possibly can about how these
things happen how they can be
communicated and also the malpractice
climate and that's very very important
to in terms of systemic changes that
perhaps need to occur in the United
States as long as physicians remain
thoroughly convinced that they are going
to invite a huge horrible medical
malpractice suit if they disclose an
error I don't think we're going to make
much progress there there will be many
of them who will just simply say look I
know that I should do it banjo you're
right ethics says I should do it I can't
do it I can't take this chance with my
career with my license you know with
with my money for heaven sakes and until
we make some significant changes there
until we can get healthcare
professionals to believe that you know
what if you are truthful if you are
transparently if you more honest if you
are empathic if you are compassionate
you will actually reduce the probability
of your being suit until we can get that
across and end up in a convincing and
persuasive way to healthcare providers I
think we're going to continue continue
to have lots of problems so dr. banner I
would like to take this time to thank
you so much for sharing your knowledge
with me and the rest of our community
and as a patient I am now realizing the
importance of having this knowledge
because as you said knowledge is power
and these are the types of issues that
everyone patients and doctors included
need to become more aware of so this has
been an incredibly enlightening session
and led me to more questions that I have
I look forward to having more
conversations
with you on these topics again i'm kate
powell with the Emory Center for Ethics
speaking with dr. John banja a medical
ethicist and the author of medical
errors and medical narcissism thank you
again dr. van de my pleasure the
preceding program is brought to you by
the Emory University's Center for Ethics